we begin this hour with a look at a very
important issue for many american
families anxiety and kids
it's a part of our special coverage for
mental health awareness month new
guidance released in april recommends
all children ages 8 to 18
should get screened for anxiety research
shows the child mind institute
non-profit dedicated to children's
mental health shows more than 30 percent
of kids and adolescents will meet the
criteria for anxiety disorder at some
point in their childhood jamie howard is
a senior clinical psychologist from the
child mind institute good morning how
are you doing jamie good morning thank
you thank you for joining us on the last
day of mental health awareness month um
but when it comes to anxiety
specifically people are hearing this age
of eight saying okay they're supposed
they're supposed to start screening at
eight years old
but they might be concerned as too young
is it too young it's not too young
actually the median age of onset of an
anxiety disorder is six years old and
the earlier we intervene right six years
old so we'll see things like separation
anxiety at that age separation anxiety
disorder selective mutism where kids um
are too scared to speak in certain
contexts so it looks a little different
in young children than it does in older
children but it starts very young okay
so do parents get their their kids
screened is that that's how it works so
what we would like is for pediatricians
to routinely do a screening at their
annual visit right so it can just take a
few questions you know so let's take the
temperature of your worries on a scale
of one to ten and how much is anxiety or
worries getting in the way of you doing
things that you would like to be doing
those are some good questions
generalized anxiety disorders what it's
called when they get a little bit older
what does that look like yeah so
generalized anxiety disorder is a more
pervasive disorder where it's
characterized by chronic worries about
everyday things so you know is it going
to rain today will i miss the bus is my
homework perfect enough did i say
something weird does she like me that
kind of thing
the symptoms you're describing like
separation anxiety when you're a little
kid isn't that normal how do you know
when because i'm just thinking what are
little kids anxious about at six and
eight yeah right well so it is normal to
have some separation anxiety when you're
little so you kind of want to look at
the intensity and you want to look at
the functional impairment so if you drop
your kid off at preschool or
kindergarten and they feel sad during
the day and they might miss you that's
normal right but if they refuse to be
dropped off and you can't get them out
the door and they really need to stay
home they worry that something bad will
happen to you if they're not with you
that's more when it's a diagnosable
disorder yeah because hearing a few of
those um anxiety issues you know
stuff with girls and boys liking each
other you know missing the bus getting
to class on time i feel like my kids
have all of those things right um but
you're saying there's something deeper
with how you communicate with them and
as parents we should try to recognize
those things yeah and with anxiety
disorders like generalized anxiety
disorder it will cause things like
difficulty sleeping headaches stomach
aches those intense chronic worries
start to take a toll and they really
interfere with kids being able to get
out in the world and do things so i'll
work with kids who need their homework
to be perfect right so they will spend
three hours writing out an assignment so
that so that's extreme that's extreme
it's taking way too long they're crying
they're tired they have so much more
work to do so what we do in
evidence-based treatment is we actually
practice turning in imperfect work so
good treatment for anxiety is very
active and we help them to face the
fears of the things that they're so
afraid of that are safe but they're
afraid where does it come from is it
something that the parents do or don't
do or is it pure where does it come from
it's usually a combination of genetics
and your environment right like some
some kids grow up in a more stressful
environment than others so that's
certainly going to take a toll we also
know that girls by adolescence are two
times more likely to have an anxiety
disorder than boys
one of the reasons might be social media
there's some data suggesting that social
media use is correlated with
internalizing disorders like anxiety and
depression girls can also be very mean i
think that's true yeah when and under
what circumstances should medication be
considered so for moderate to more
severe anxiety disorders the combination
of cognitive behavioral therapy and
medicine is what the research shows is
most effective so the medicine sort of
helps you to get a quicker response but
then the therapy is so important for the
long-lasting response some of the things
that we see as adults cause causes
anxiety
is is there a rise in anxiety in
children because of let's just say
school shootings mass shootings that are
happening almost you know every other
week that's a hypothesis that a lot of
us have that there's a lot of pressure
nowadays on kids there's high
performance anxiety
and then there's things that are just
very dangerous in the world and we have
access to it we can see it all through
social media through constant um
coverage through our devices and like
you've said before that's why it's
important to have those conversations
about things that are going on in
society exactly right and and some
anxiety is adaptive right like we don't
want to just say anxiety is bad it's
actually designed to keep us safe if
you're being chased by a giant bear and
you run away from it
yeah your anxiety helped you it's just
that when your anxiety gets in the way
and you're afraid of things that are
safe and it's keeping you from living
your life that's when it's a problem all
right jamie howard thank you always good
to have you at the table thank you